my name is Jurgen I'm the CEO and
founder of street football world an
organization that develops and
coordinates a network of close to 100
organizations grassroots organizations
all over the world who use football as a
tool for social transformation social
change I will take two questions from
our boosters one is what keeps you
motivated the other one is what was the
most interesting idea I heard at the
forum and one question from Bray who is
asking for the distinguishing strength
of Latin America so as you heard street
football world where we are dealing with
football as a tool for social
development and as you might know there
is a world cup coming up in in Brazil in
2014 what we believe and this is what I
believe is the strength of Latin America
the passion of the people and especially
linked football what we believe might be
the catalyst to really go a step further
than just talking about collaboration
and do collaboration so this world cup
which offers a platform for Latin
America to show to the world for us is
the opportunity to really get into
collaboration to create not only a
social legacy for Brazil and for the
Latin American region but to create
models of how to work together to weave
networks that will give a lasting legacy
for the region and this takes me to the
question what keeps me motivated what
makes me get up in the morning
is that I believe that we have to
overcome ego we have to overcome brands
if we really want to achieve what our
command mission should be which is to
eradicate poverty so everybody invited
to be part of it